The Legend of Tarzan is directed by
David Yates the man who brought us some
of the best Harry Potter films as well
as this year's upcoming fantastic beasts
and where to find them and stars
alexander skarsgård as the screaming
yelling ape loving guy who swings around
and vines who since become civilized
he's married to Jane played by Margot
Robbie that live in a beautiful home in
England but he gets called back to the
jungle when this scheme is brought about
by Christoph Waltz's character that
enslaves an entire population of people
he's got to dig inside himself to revert
back to that primal instinct that he
once had to try to save the jungle once
again not a single bit of me was excited
for this movie I am NOT a fan of Tarzan
he is a popular character he's been
around since the early 1900's he was
created by Edgar Rice Burroughs and I
think this film is about as good as a
live-action Tarzan film could really be
today it actually did surprise me it is
not great there are some issues that I
have with this movie but overall I think
it will entertain you especially if you
are a fan of Tarzan like if he is a
character you grew up with or maybe you
loved the Disney animated film from 1999
overall The Legend of Tarzan is better
than I thought it was going to be there
isn't that much to get you into it it's
a little bit hollow emotionally there's
a lot of flashback sequences where you
learn about Tarzan's past things that
happen with other tribes men who lived
in the jungle at that time it's supposed
to make you care and make you more into
the moment but it just didn't do that
for me because a lot of it does feel
very rushed Christoph Waltz is finding
the movie as this villain who enslaves
Jane and other tribes people and Tarzan
has to save everybody and he yells and
swings from vines and you expected all
that and for the most part it's done
fairly well it's just that at its core I
had a tough time really getting that
invested Alexander Skarsgard is really
good as this character he embodies
pretty much everything that the original
novels were he's a kind generous spirit
he understands humans well but he also
understands animals well he's huge
skarsgård is like six foot four and he's
very buff in this movie he definitely
portrays the physicality very well the
story surrounding all of these elements
sort of just feels like an excuse to
have Tarzan eventually swing around on
vines and do his Tarzan yell
there isn't that much there and the
elements of the story that do feel like
they have more emotional weights are so
rushed and things are solved so quickly
and sort of brushed aside and never
mentioned again that it feels like wait
why didn't you focus more on that that
was definitely more compelling than
Christoph Waltz and his scheme to make
money the best part of this movie for me
and I've been saving this for the end
for a reason samuel l.jackson I didn't
know much about his character in this
movie I only saw the teaser so I didn't
know how much he was going to be in this
movie but he has a big substantial role
he's by far having the most fun of
anyone he feels like he's having fun and
that's another issue I did have with
this movie it's Tarzan where's the fun
we need some fun this movie is really
self serious and I understand that his
wife is kidnapped and people are being
enslaved and the jungle animals are
being threatened but this is a guy who
swings around on vines in a jungle
screams the top of his lungs and can
control the animals this should be a ton
of fun but the movie really gets
painfully dramatic and serious and
you're like where's the fun let's have
some good times here and that's why I
liked Sam Jackson in this movie so much
because he was the one guy who was like
yeah guys happy to be here he's smiling
he's having a good time I'm being more
harsh on this movie because I've seen
David Yates do great things with the
Harry Potter universe and I expect one
of his films to be really good and this
is fine I think for a Tarzan movie I
mean I there's not much anticipation for
me for Tarzan and I think they did the
best job they could with what they had
to work with in regards to Tarzan and
bring him into the modern age it's just
that this movie should have been a ton
more fun and it's too serious in my mind
I'm not saying they should have had Phil
Collins do the soundtrack or anything
and it's certainly better than whatever
the hell that thing was that came out of
2013 the action is exciting there's a
very good opening scene some of the
music is really good
skarsgård is great as the character
Margot Robbie is entertaining as Jane
there are some very cool side characters
like samuel l.jackson Christoph Waltz is
just fine but the movie itself as a
whole just failed to come
tell me I'm going to give The Legend of
Tarzan a C+ I do want to give you this
caveat though if you are a huge fan of
Tarzan like if you were just pumped out
of your mind for this movie I think
you'll probably really dig it because it
does respect that character as someone
who isn't really a fan of the character
though but does have a knowledge of his
roots I can appreciate that the
characters being respected it just
didn't really entertain me that much
because the stories surrounding all the
cool things you can see it kind of just
deflated in the end so guys gonna have
some more reviews for you coming very
soon the BFG Spielberg's new movies
coming out this weekend I'm going to
review all three Bourne films before
Jason Bourne comes out I want to do
revitalize new more in-depth reviews of
those movies for you so I'm going to
have the Bourne Identity very soon I
also have three retro rewinds I've
already filmed I'm just looking for a
nice sufficient gap in which I can
release them there's been so many new
releases and speaking of Jason Bourne we
are planning something very cool a very
cool Bourne skit that we're going to
incorporate with the Jason Bourne review
in some way I'm excited to bring that to
you guys as always if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck my
nice